this is the most popular show on the
globe the premiere had to be crazy the
Game of Thrones premiere did you have a
good time don't you get to meet people
that you know it was your mind blown
sufficiently my mom was kind of blown
yeah just just seeing everybody from the
cast is exciting enough but I've seen
them quite a few times right right
looks like me saying Wow Andy Richter
which which I do say everyday yeah there
was some interest in faces there were
some interesting people the one that
really got me excited was Dave Chappelle
Oh Dave Chappelle of course Dave
Chappelle was there and I've been a fan
of Dave Chappelle for a long time and
wouldn't you find out the Dave Chappelle
likes the show it's so exciting for a
very specific reason it's really killing
all of my friends at home like it's
killing them because a lot of my friends
have a kind of prejudice about fantasy
and they're like fantasy sure you say
probably not gonna watch that probably
not gonna watch that one probably a
little bit cool I'm probably a little
bit too cool to be watching fantasy
shows and you're like okay Dave
Chappelle watches it though so I mean I
don't know if you try to say that you're
cooler than Dave Chappelle I hate to
break it to you pal
yeah ah yeah two things I think you're
absolutely right about if Dave Chappelle
likes it it must be cool second thing is
your friends are shitty it's kind of
thrown those are terrible people
well they've often said that that
they've tried to watch it yeah and tried
is a big word
yeah we've really tried to watch this
and they say we like it and then you're
there yeah and then you're suddenly
there yeah are we supposed to invest in
this world this is me talking to my
father about this show little Africa
I like it but then you're there
yes I'm a central cog in this whole
thing dad
you got a did you get a photo with Dave
Chappelle I would think if he's your
hero that would be oh my god I don't
drink
Dave drinks with a capital D it kind of
occurred to me that night and we had a
photograph taken and when you see the
photograph you'll see I'm the one who's
not been drinking in this photograph it
was one of those horrible moments where
I blinked at precisely the wrong moment
when the photograph was taken
I blasted Dave look Dave looks like he's
just rolled outta breath it difficult I
bet he looks so fresh yeah and I look
like the wand that Dave Chappelle should
stay away from yeah let's take a look
here I'm curious
[Laughter]
look at Dave's glasses I've never seen
him wear those are huge glasses yeah
yeah you have a good view of me looking
like
[Laughter]